if you want to get a politician to
change the subject ask them how they're
going to deal with the federal debt
that's what happened when I asked Vivek
ramaswamy what he would do to cut
spending he said he'd Focus instead on
supercharging the economy so that we can
grow our way out of it we've grown at
more than four plus percent GDP growth
for most of our national history if we
get back to a three-handle three point
something actually most of those fiscal
problems are completely gone since 1970
annual GDP growth has averaged 2.7
percent so what happens if ramaswamy
becomes president and is actually able
to unleash economic growth that pushes
the U.S economy to average four percent
annual GDP growth for two full terms
would most of our fiscal problems be
completely gone not even close the
projected deficit would be cut almost in
half but the government would still be
running red ink every year and the
federal debt would just keep growing